Okay.
Let's start in,
got a fairly large agenda today
and I wanted to remind you that next
week we're moving on to air quality.
So check your syllabus and,
uh,
read the material for section next week.
And today I want to talk
about key principles in law,
uh,
one being preemption and
the other being defamation.
And to give you a couple of case histories
and I'm going to start out talking
about Bates v Dow.
And then I want to talk about two cases,
one on product disparagement,
uh,
and the other one is known as the LR case.
Uh,
and another is a case that was brought
by the Texas cattleman's association
against Oprah Winfrey.
And I'll show you a couple
of video clips of that.
First of all,
preemption has its origin
in the constitution,
uh,
within the supremacy clause.
It states this constitution and the laws
of the u s shall be the supreme law of
the land.
And the judges in every
state shall be bound thereby,
so that within air quality law,
within a pesticide management law,
within pharmaceutical law,
uh,
tobacco law,
occupational law,
uh,
states are prohibited
from adopting standards,
certain standards,
uh,
that are,
different than the federal government.
And the purpose behind
this is not to create a,
a,
a patchwork quilt that,
uh,
is really comprised of
nonuniform standards.
So that a,
when corporations wish to trade goods,
uh,
or provide services
across state boundaries,
they basically had the same expectations.
It's often applied to situations that
are risky or products that are risky.
And the failure to warn is often a key
question and we'll raise that in the
case.
Today we respect to pesticides.
Uh,
Congress traditionally deferred to
states to regulate threats to health and
safety,
uh,
but since 1970,
it's exercises power,
uh,
to preempt state or local regulation,
in a number of areas,
particularly,
uh,
with respect to warning
labels on pesticides.
So there are a variety of
theories of damage recovery.
So if you imagine that,
uh,
say,
someone comes to your home and,
uh,
promises to give you a green lawn,
by applying fertilizers
and insecticides and a,
all of a sudden,
you know,
you notice an accurate,
uh,
a taste in your well water and also your,
your,
uh,
children start to feel awkward or strange.
Uh,
can you find out that the chemicals
that were applied were neurotoxic
substances?
Uh,
and,
and what,
what are your rights?
Uh,
basically you could argue that we have a,
we have a percussion
section out there in the,
in the,
uh,
on the street throwing I think a rocks
or bricks into one of these big metal
barrels.
So I apologize for that.
So you can imagine yourself in a situation
where you conclude that federal law
didn't protect you against that,
uh,
you feel like you've been damaged.
It's going to cost you money to either
drill a new well or to put in filtration
equipment.
And what about the health
effects on your family?
Uh,
so there,
there are a variety of theories
of damage recovery and one is,
uh,
that,
the failure to warn provides
a justification for seeking
a recovery of damages.
So,
uh,
remember what I argued about the,
the difficulty that,
uh,
most people have an understanding,
warning labels,
uh,
the,
the difficulty of taking complicated
scientific information and,
and reducing it in a way that
would make it intelligible and,
and make you capable of knowing,
you know,
how you should behave in
order to prevent risks.
For example,
uh,
should you have,
should you be responsible to know that
you have sandy soils and that your well
is a shallow well and it's an old
well and the casing is cracked?
I mean,
are you really responsible to know that a,
should that information
be on a warning label?
Negligence is another theory for recovery.
So was the,
uh,
the product,
made in a negligent way or was
it used in a negligent way?
How about design defects?
Uh,
listening to good morning America today.
I was intrigued by litigation that,
uh,
is,
is growing,
uh,
class action suits against Toyota because
of their accelerator pad catching or a
brake defects.
So,
uh,
some,
some defect in production or,
or design that leads to a higher level,
a higher concentration of risk
or hazard in subsequent damage.
How about a failure to
disclose incident reports?
So that Dow Chemical Company was,
was fine,
nearly $800,000,
uh,
because it had been,
reported it to Dow by a variety of,
uh,
families that,
that they felt that,
uh,
they had,
medical problems that were associated
with using their products and,
uh,
they were required under federal
pesticide law to report those incidents,
uh,
back to the environmental
protection agency.
Uh,
and they did not do so
within the time limit,
there was a significant delay.
So the failure to disclose
incident reports and again,
with the,
the,
uh,
auto defects that,
we're,
we're a witnessing and the,
in the press and,
and,
uh,
in the showrooms today,
the same issue applies.
So when did the corporation
know that the pedals stuck,
uh,
or that the brake system,
was,
uh,
not working.
So the failure to,
uh,
to report back to,
to,
uh,
government agencies that have
regulatory responsibilities,
whether it's pharmaceuticals or,
or cars or,
or pesticides or cosmetics or foods.
Uh,
these generally carry
significant penalties.
And
because of preemption that's built
into pesticide law and air quality law,
et Cetera,
uh,
states have often denied access to courts,
to use these theories of recovery to,
to secure compensation so that
the state courts have often,
uh,
not agreed to hear the cases.
Uh,
this is why a Bates,
the Dow is so important.
Uh,
Bates is a case in which a
29 peanut growers in Texas,
uh,
allege that Dow agrosciences,
had,
had produced a chemical called strong arm,
a strong arm.
They claim damage there.
Peanut plants back in the
year 2000 and the plate,
the pesticide label itself claim that,
uh,
use of strong arm as recommended in
all areas where peanuts are grown.
Now when it was used in the Texas a peanut
farm land where the soils exceeded a
Ph of 7.2,
it damaged both the peanut crop
and it feel to control the weeds.
So,
uh,
the,
the activity of this chemical is
mediated by the acidity of the soil.
Uh,
and by 2001 EPA approved a
new label for the chemical,
including a new warning,
do not apply strong arm to soils
with a Ph of 7.2 or greater.
So this case was decided in
2005 a this label was in,
in force,
uh,
for four years before the,
the decision date.
So eventually,
uh,
the case wound its way
up to the supreme court.
And this is quite,
this is quite a feat in many instances.
Uh,
claims that are brought in state courts,
uh,
do not make their way
up to the supreme court,
can often take decades or
even a half a century before,
uh,
cases is believed to be appropriate for
judicial review by the highest court in
the country.
So they found the congress surely would
have expressed its intent more clearly
if it had meant to deprive injured
parties of along available form of
compensation.
Moreover,
this history emphasizes the importance
of providing an incentive to
manufacturers to use the utmost care
and distributing inhere inherently
dangerous items.
In other words,
the Supreme Court was looking at,
uh,
the,
these,
uh,
lawsuits to seek recovery
is really a last resort.
So it represents the
failure of federal law.
It represents the failure of state
law or local law to offer sufficient
environmental protection or
protection of public health.
So what's a damaged party to do?
What are you going to do
if you've been damaged?
Well,
you,
you probably would consider litigation.
So the Supreme Court,
uh,
continued.
It seems likely unlikely that Congress
considered a relatively obscure
provision,
like section one 36 VB,
uh,
which is a preemption clause to get
pesticide manufacturers virtual immunity
from certain forms of tort liability.
And we'd been pointed to no evidence
that such tort suits lead led to a crazy
quilt of Fifth Fra,
federal pesticide law standards,
or otherwise created any real
hardship for manufacturers or EPA.
So the argument that you would
have an unequal on uneven,
uh,
regulatory playing field among the states,
had no substance to it or
that the manufacturers would
be damaged significantly
by,
uh,
by these claims because a,
they're expensive,
they're time consuming,
and a few people actually have the
resources or capacity to bring,
uh,
the,
the lawsuits.
So central questions today really a will
involve a question of freedom of speech
and when is it appropriate
to limit speech about,
uh,
environmental and health hazards,
intellectual property rights,
you know,
who should own the right
to a knowledge of risk?
Should it be,
uh,
should corporations be
capable of holding that as a,
a,
a secret or are they out?
Should they be obligated
to disclose that to uh,
to the public in the form of a warning
label or a disclosure of an incident
report?
What should the standard of proof
be a and how should the falsity of a
statement,
uh,
be judged the falsity of the statement
on a label or the falsity of a statement
made by a party,
uh,
that is challenging a corporation that
they were damaged by exposure to their
product.
Uh,
and where should the burden of proof
watch or the burden of proof why with a
plaintiff to prove the
falsity of criticism or the
defendant approve a truth of,
of criticism and to,
to uh,
uh,
explore this area of product
disparagement a more fully.
I want you to consider one case.
Uh,
this is a case of a,
of a chemical known as Al are,
uh,
that,
can,
you probably did not experience,
uh,
but,
it was in wide use in
the United States and,
uh,
in different parts of the world,
back in the 1980s and early 1990s.
And it was used on apples and
it was used on apple orchards.
Basically to cause a stem thickening.
Uh,
so it would hold the apple on the tree
longer and it would keep the apple from
falling down and getting bruised.
So it would maintain the commercial
quality and the great of the Apple.
And it would also cause uniform ripening.
Uniform ripening is important because
you don't want part of a tree,
perhaps that's facing the sunshine,
uh,
to have apples that are ripe.
And then the,
the,
uh,
all the,
apples that are,
uh,
on the north side of the tree,
in more shade that would remain green.
So it provided economic advantage to,
to orchard owners,
uh,
in,
in a variety of ways.
It's,
this is a systemic compound,
which is interesting.
It means that it's absorbed up through
the plant roots itself into the plant
tissue.
So,
uh,
you may think that,
some residues are only on the
surface of a fruit or a vegetable,
and if you peel it or if you wash it,
you could get rid of it.
Here's an example of,
of a compound that,
uh,
that would not be helpful for.
It's not easy to detect.
Uh,
when this chemical was
being reviewed and became a,
uh,
public,
public target,
uh,
for criticism of,
of its manufacturer.
Uh,
I went up to,
uh,
the state of Massachusetts because the
state of Massachusetts with trying to
figure out if they were going to
ban the compound as it was detected
increasingly in foods.
And I went to their laboratories,
their state laboratories,
and they had not even developed a
detection method yet speaking to their
analytic chemist.
They couldn't,
they didn't even know how
to find this in foods.
So thinking about that,
what that means is that the government
approved the use of a chemical on certain
crops when it knew that there was no
accepted method for detecting it in a,
in the food or in,
in processed forms of the food,
uh,
or in water supplies if it,
if it happened to
contaminate water supplies.
So that's,
that's quite curious and it
might give you some ideas,
uh,
about,
prior requirements before
introducing new technologies.
So it gives,
uh,
it has an unusual characteristic.
It produces a unsymmetrical
die methyl hydrazine,
Udm h,
which is also a space shuttle rocket fuel,
but only under conditions
where the chemical is heated.
Now,
where would a food be heated?
Well,
it's commonly heated when
it's so when it's processed,
uh,
or when it's pasteurized.
So,
uh,
when you take an apple
and you grind it up and,
and uh,
uh,
you squeeze all the juice out
of it and to make apple juice,
uh,
it's commonly heated up for the purposes
of killing bacteria and protecting
human health.
Apple juice,
uh,
at in the 1980s was also exploding into
the marketplace and in part because of,
of different,
uh,
packaging technologies.
So it used to be available
in large glass bottles,
uh,
but the,
the advent of juice boxes,
uh,
so that the children would take,
these,
these flavored juices to school on a
routine basis and in a really small
cardboard and plastic containers,
it costs,
caused apple juice
consumption to skyrocket.
So that apple juice within
a matter of a decade,
uh,
became one of the more heavily
consumed foods by young children.
So it was introduced by Uniroyal in 1966,
uh,
and registered by the
Department of Agriculture
because EPA wasn't in existence
until 1970 and in 1973 a,
it was found to produce cancer in mice.
Uh,
between 1977 and 78,
the National Cancer Institute,
uh,
found that that study
was credible and they,
they conducted their own studies,
uh,
that found carcinogenic
effects in animals.
You know,
raising the question,
how should we look at data
from animal testing and what,
what should we infer from that
about a human health risk?
Well,
during conservative
political administrations,
we've tended as a society,
not to worry too much about,
uh,
these,
these low level cancer
risks in the food supply.
But remember that at this point in time,
the Delaney clause in the Food Drug and
cosmetic act was in place that had what
was called the de Minimus
risk standard built into it.
So it also had the food and
Drug Administration that
was interpreting the de
standard to allow low
levels of risk in the,
in the food supply.
So EPA concluded eventually in
1980 that it was carcinogenic,
uh,
and then negotiated with
Uniroyal for several years.
And that produced no action.
Uh,
in 1985,
they found that both Lr,
which is the parent
compound and the metabolite,
the Udm h was a probable human carcinogen.
So this is the next step
up in the level of concern.
It's not just an animal carcinogen,
probable human,
uh,
the next step up by the way,
is known human carcinogen.
Uh,
and there are more than a hundred now,
uh,
compounds that are,
are characterized as
known human carcinogens,
such as benzene and,
uh,
a one three Butte,
Butte of dying,
which exists in diesel exhaust and,
uh,
other,
combustion,
uh,
situations such as in wood smoke or,
or,
uh,
hm.
Virtually anytime fossil fuel is,
is,
uh,
being combusted.
And in 1985,
uh,
some feedback from their own
scientific advisory panel,
uh,
raise questions about
the quality of the data,
can you actually calculate a cancer risk?
So what is the threat,
uh,
and what can publicly be
stated about that threat?
Well,
the natural resources defense council,
one of our largest environmental groups,
uh,
conducted their own analysis of,
of kids' exposure,
recognizing that kids were eating a
lot of apples and apple sauce and,
and drinking a lot of apple juice.
It was a very common,
uh,
drink to be served to infants in,
in place of,
of infant formula or milk and has
the EPA violated the public trust.
So let me see if I can get this going.
This is a 60 minutes report
that was prepared on this,
uh,
controversy so that the Natural
Resources Defense Council,
uh,
brought their study to
16 minutes and ask them,
would you like to release
this information on your show?
And,
uh,
the,
answer was yes.
Who was
most of
you met him some data from this one call
for more than one a year down
the EPA that the EPA is known
about the cancer for 16 years.
There's no question.
Uh,
you told me something that,
I mean,
it's brand new.
It wouldn't get on the market because we,
you
one of the
pesticide gets it,
the license gets it.
It's on the market despite
what everybody might think.
The burden of carrying a reasonable
response basically goes onto the golf.
All right,
Margaret Prosecutors.
What you're saying,
we can't take them off because they were
already on the market and they went on
the market.
We didn't know that.
That's,
that's the paradox.
Is it fair to say more than there are
laws on the books that are putting,
all of us particularly are filled quickly,
quickly
while Dr. Warren Law,
which requires him to balance the
health risks to the public against the
economic benefits to the growers,
Congressman Juries of course,
but
why is the flu?
Because our laboratory animal not
being pulled off the market.
Jack,
you'd like to take it off the but
the manufacturer oil.
It makes us capable of good,
successful.
Let us show.
That's his job.
He's with the environment I
all
wasting away a kid and then
the benefit
that
he drinks so much apple juice,
preschoolers race 18 times where apple,
who's done his or her mother.
If those apples,
the cancer risk is,
hi John Hathaway,
he's a senior attorney for the
natural resources defense council
agent news.
But Aka going to cause cancer children
with a lot of time you chemical,
which makes the design under the three
our declined to be interviewed for this
record or in the letter they said,
[inaudible] give you that exists
is negligible nonetheless,
preliminary results from your own study
already young high levels of cancer in
the laboratory
to say defendant's counsel has
completed the most careful study.
Yeah,
it will be effective in that aside.
And seven
what,
what
the level of cancer,
what that means is that
one.
What about parents?
[inaudible] one
[inaudible] [inaudible] it doesn't cost.
You kind of
need to send his children would be,
it was several hundred times.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
This will take just one second.
Yeah.
So think about what Janet Hathaway,
the senior attorney just
said over a lifetime.
One child that out of every 4,000 or so
of our preschoolers will develop cancer
from just these eight pesticides.
I think about the wording.
The phrasing got very carefully.
This is quantitative risk assessment.
It's loaded with uncertainty
from many different sources.
You're,
you're forced to infer
from animal evidence.
You're forced to,
to,
uh,
understand,
the,
the pattern of exposure,
uh,
how the compound might
behave inside the human body.
Uh,
then she said,
Al are the most potent con cancer causing
and our food supply as a substance
sprayed on apples to keep
them on the trees longer.
Uh,
and what we're talking about is a cancer
causing agent used on food that EPA
knows is going to cause cancer
for thousands of children,
uh,
over their lifetime.
These are our,
uh,
statements a of,
of certainty,
uh,
that,
caused widespread fear in the population.
Senator Joe Lieberman spoke to me,
uh,
during this situation and he said he
walked immediately after watching 60
minutes over to his refrigerator,
he took out his jar of apple juice and
dumped it down the drain and started
making phone calls.
This happened to all over the country
is millions of people who had witnessed
this,
a Jack Moore,
uh,
who you saw the acting
EPA administrator said,
uh,
that the evidence,
yes,
uh,
that he relied upon was suitable for a
decision to say that Al r and D was a
carcinogen.
And the media reaction
was really quite striking.
Uh,
all of the major media
outlets pick this story up.
Newsweek,
et Cetera,
Donahue on the Donahue show.
Uh,
he said,
don't look now,
but we're poisoning our kids.
Uh,
the consumer reaction was really quite
a rapid and a devastating for the apple
industry.
A apple product sales
dropped 30% in a month,
uh,
particularly on apple juice school
boards in New York and Virginia and
California stop serving apples
in their lunch programs.
Uh,
growers claimed losses of
$250 million and engaged,
uh,
they engage in a lawsuit against both
60 minutes as well as the natural
resources defense council.
Uh,
within a matter of six months.
The economic,
uh,
concerns were so high that the industry
itself was begging EPA to please
regulate and prohibit
the use of this chemical.
Now that's really quite striking.
So that you've got a really,
a,
kind of a very different type
of regulatory theory here.
Uh,
what is regulation doing?
it's really providing a
sense of legitimacy to
manufacturers of different kinds
of products so that if you know
that a chemical or product didn't,
it could be a food,
it could be a car,
uh,
if you know that it's been reviewed by,
by a regulatory agency,
uh,
that act of regulation
a really constitutes
certification of that products,
a utility and also its
safety in the marketplace.
So the fact that the,
uh,
the,
the growers and the grocery stores and
even Uniroyal asked Epa to move quickly,
uh,
so that the economic damage,
would be limited and consumer
confidence could be restored,
particularly because this product
was not used on all apple products.
So it really is a form
of symbolic politics,
which I think is quite striking.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
regardless of whether or not the
regulations are health protective,
uh,
they create a sense of legitimacy of
products and services in the marketplace.
So that in one sense,
uh,
are our corporations
need these regulations,
uh,
so that,
they,
uh,
create consumer confidence.
So the Washington apple growers,
there are 4,700 of them claimed that
while there was no evidence linking Al
already human cancer and the
animal evidence was insufficient,
uh,
and they called this a,
product disparagement,
trade libel case.
Uh,
and in this situation,
the growers face the burden of proof.
So they needed to prove that the
statements were made knowingly,
uh,
and to be false,
the statements were deliberately
made to induce monetary damage.
And this is a form of trade libel law,
defamation.
Uh,
so there are,
there are several forms of,
of uh,
uh,
libel slander and sedition libel.
A,
the definition is defamation
through print materials.
Slander is oral defamation,
ah,
in the English common law,
tradition,
libel and private enterprise,
I generally found
favorably to a plaintiffs.
And sedition you'll recall
is any political criticism
that tended to diminish
respect for government
laws and public officials.
Common law definition of libel,
I was decided,
uh,
by,
a famous court case in 1933.
It covers all written communications
that tend to expose one to public hatred,
Shame Co Obloquy,
uh,
cartoon Lee,
Odm contempt,
ridicule aversion,
ostracism,
degradation or disgrace,
and to induce and evil opinion,
uh,
of one in the minds of right
thinking persons into the pride,
one of their confidence and
friendly intercourse in society.
Well,
in this case,
the Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals,
uh,
found,
on the absence of human studies at the
fact that there have been no studies
conducted specifically on the cancer
risks to children from diminish side.
One of the arguments on the part of the
industry that does nothing to disprove
the conclusion that of children consume
more of a carcinogenic substance than do
adults.
They are at higher risk
for contracting cancer.
So what's interesting about this comment
by the appellate court is that they're
not looking for proof that this
chemical caused cancer in children.
They're looking for elevated cancer risk.
And on the falsity of the statements,
uh,
product disparagement,
plaintiff has the burden
of proving the falsity.
Uh,
and this statement refers
to individuals not to the,
any overall message.
And if a jury were given the task of
interpreting the uncertain Eva a message,
uh,
it raises the specter of a
chilling effect on speech.
So,
uh,
think about,
the relationship between,
uh,
this type of a court case and the
freedom of the individual to express
themselves or express their opinion about
the dangers of different products or,
or human behaviors.
Uh,
so this case was decided by the night
circuit fundamentally on a First
Amendment,
a choice referring back to a,
a famous New York Times
versus Sullivan case in 1964.
We're Sullivan who was
a police in Alabama,
uh,
brought a libel action against four
African American clergy and the New York
Times.
Uh,
the times had published an
advertisement back in 1960,
uh,
in supportive of a civil
rights activism among students,
uh,
a struggle for the right to vote,
a legal defense of Martin Luther King
against a perjury charge and charges of
repressive police misconduct,
including false statements.
And the trial judge had instructed the
jury that the advertisement was liable,
liable is that a legal injury was implied
that falsity and malice or presumed.
And the punitive damages
should be awarded.
So that in this case,
the Supreme Court found that
constitutionally deficient.
It was constitutionally deficient for
failure to safeguard freedom of speech.
And the press are required by the first
and the 14th amendment and debate on
public issues should be uninhibited,
robust,
wide open,
and that it may well include vehement,
caustic and sharp attacks on
government and public officials
with respect to actual malice.
Because in order to,
to find a disparagement,
uh,
or liability in this situation,
there's a need to
demonstrate actual malice.
The constitutional guarantees require
a federal rule that prohibits,
prohibits a public official
from recovering damages
for defamatory false hood
relating to his official conduct unless
he proves that the statement was made
with actual malice.
What's malice?
Well,
it's with knowledge that,
uh,
the claim was false when it was made or
with reckless disregard of whether it
was false,
false,
and the burden of demonstrating
the falsity a rests on the planet.
Now
this seems to give the media a fairly
wide berth and the kinds of claims that
they can make
in the wake of this case,
uh,
many states passed what
are thought of now and,
and,
uh,
labeled as Veggie libel laws.
So that rather than
placing the burden on a,
uh,
a plaintiff to demonstrate,
the falsity of the statement,
uh,
they placed the burden on the individual
that makes the claim of significant
risk or hazard.
So there are many states that
have adopted the statutory change.
And what this means is that it
opens the way for slap suits.
Uh,
what does a slap suit?
It basically is a suit
that intimidates people,
uh,
from making claims about,
the,
the quality of the environment or causes
of its loss or a subsequent health
damages.
So,
uh,
among these 20 or so states
that have adopted these laws,
for example,
now I will not give a lecture a
where I'm making a claim of risk,
uh,
so that what might be thought of as a
chilling effect on free speech in a way.
So if I'm,
uh,
say,
being taped on a radio show,
that radio show is broadcast in a,
in a,
a state where,
where one of these
veggie libel laws exist,
that would place the burden on
me to demonstrate the proof,
uh,
that my claim is,
is uh,
uh,
backed up by high quality science,
that will pull me into court.
It will cost me thousands of dollars,
hundreds of thousands of dollars even,
uh,
to,
to uh,
defend myself.
So that the influence of,
of this,
this form of,
of law,
uh,
is really quite striking.
What also is interesting about this,
this evolution of state laws that,
that a reverse,
the burden of proof is that clearly
it's been found by the Supreme Court is
being,
uh,
an unconstitutional shift in the burden.
Yet none of these state laws have been
taken up to the Supreme Court for,
for consideration.
So think,
think about that.
Uh,
these laws had been in place
now for well over a decade and,
uh,
all environmental groups,
all public health interest groups
understand the nature of these laws and
they're all very self conscious.
About the nature of the
claims that they make.
Now I want to show you this.
Uh,
Oprah Winfrey,
ah,
had a Ho had hosted a
show on mad cow disease.
Mad cow disease is a,
a,
an illness that is caused by a prion and
believe to be associated with beef that
are fed other cattle parts,
uh,
in their,
cattle meal.
So Winfrey hosted Howard Lyman,
uh,
who described the process of,
of a slaughter houses and a beef rendering
and how the parts were ground up,
uh,
and then,
put into animal feed and fed
back in the United States to a,
to cattle that were sold for food.
Uh,
and this was the,
the,
uh,
mechanism that,
he and others believed had had caused
the outbreak of mad cow disease in Great
Britain.
Now there are laws that
prevent that from happening,
but at this point in time,
this represents another,
a rather interesting case on,
on a product disparagement
cannot locate.
Give me one second here.
I've lost my Internet connection.
So we're on hold for a moment.
Sign back
online
within
10 years.
And she said,
what about a hundred thousand
cars a year or two in the morning?
We run the block,
he come back,
we will move,
kills your belt.
Possible raccoons Frisch
from up off the street,
granted him up then back of house and
then we can the city of Los Angeles,
200 tons of peps or chemicals that were
used to kill that 200 tons a month for
ground up,
terminated a few better back for this
type of corporate partners and sausage,
I think knew it to that gut.
She turns around and watches the guy
from the national cattleman's beef
association of sense.
Doctor,
what work are we feeding?
Empowers to cows?
And that the city said,
well,
you know,
I'll listen to the month of that going on.
I believe in about 95%
of the cattle in fact,
and feed blood to be being a
remains above the ground level.
And the next day,
uh,
awkward smile them,
gets the soup,
offer a service that just stops me.
I will never him eager worker.
Now she couldn't say,
she didn't say that.
Millions of yours,
you shouldn't meet him.
She just said that soft Nicole,
I will never get the burger.
Now I know what I want to know about show.
The 13 states had a thing called
the fruit of the spirit of the law.
The point of [inaudible] say something
that you felt to be false about a
perishable commodity.
Say anything.
I thought to be false.
Aye Recruit.
Well,
we we're taking,
we refill.
Took about two hours.
When we got it done,
I said,
give me 10 minutes.
I'll just came
to me and said,
so I went about my business
a couple of weeks later.
Got a call.
He said,
you realize you're being sued,
Oprah Winfrey,
but it moved with Texas
capital bank and they said,
no,
I agree.
Sit In my library inventory.
Buy Vegetarian cookbooks.
I knew those settlement,
one of those 53 and cookbook just bad.
I went back and said,
I can't talk to you right now.
I'm going to put in a call the Oprah.
I called over to the left
a message and I said,
if we lose this soup,
I throw it in my bed and cook the books.
You got to put up the money.
Well,
we ended up getting sued in Emerald,
Texas.
I don't know how many of you
ever been to Amarillo infections.
It's not the end of the world.
Clearly visible.
You're going to give the world,
take the hose and we're rural Texas.
The water who said employer and rural
Texas happens to be the slaughter facility
killing bumper stickers all over town
on sending me the only bad cut on the
Texas.
His name.
I knew we were in trouble and
I don't want you to solve them.
We need a change of venue,
the way the world,
but if we could win,
so we file with the judge where it
change the basically when you walk in,
because the devil,
72 year old lady up tuffle knackered.
We asked for,
we've been used to picks up the hammer,
slaps it down,
says emotions and I bring
it to the jury pool.
They're going 140 people and
you never saw so many hats.
Boots in the boat will
hopes and all your life.
I said to my lawyer,
we may need to file an appeal because
there's a world of look in the window
here.
[inaudible] was a big head call.
Drew's absolutely steeped
in the cattle culture.
What lawyer you put 78 he said the call
calling you to the spanner tomorrow.
He said,
the first question [inaudible]
I said,
I could have left.
You said you damn well better.
We'll lose who
the point of some turning is.
Looking at the new laughing and giggling
and he says Kevin Hart to say this
but determinative [inaudible] apologize
for something that is saving my life.
Never again.
Kyle did.
They ever asked me about Turner,
but they asked me every question that
you can have that I want on the sale of
the owner looks at me and he says,
anybody ever called you responsible?
I said,
yes.
My lawyer was sitting over there going,
no,
no.
The plaintiff's attorney,
he thinks he's keeping
the Gordon uses home.
I said mine majority is
over there and been there,
done that.
We were in that courtroom for six weeks.
At the end of the six weeks that jury
found the Oprah Harpo production of myself
not allowable
plane is when other the trinity.
They couldn't imagine that during that
home room cause fine out with toddlers
appeal with the Fifth
Circuit Court of thing.
We spent a year in the Fifth Circuit Court
of Appeals and at the end of the year
they came down with a group of us pill.
The sooner the overall
production of myself or not
allowable and then they wrote
an opinion of it said every
fanged on the land and set up.
The show was truthful
and it is not actionable.
The California couldn't stand up that as
the war or retail.
It was the knowledge that account is
what the shape court file Souvik as oil
production and myself and seek
court and God are you at in Texas?
I was with a woman from
the city of course,
but the federal court,
they people back,
we said six years,
hundreds of thousands of dollars on mine.
Ranomi definitive to tell the truth
at the end of secures is doing the
fucking threw up the case with prejudice,
the jury front of the
complainants who not.
And we filed the case that
sent you the little
pictures of a little bit of,
again,
we're standing.
Tell them.
Okay.
So the core of this problem is the way
that these state veggie libel law shift
the burden of proof.
So under federal law,
it's really clear that uh,
the cattleman's association was under the,
the burden of proof to demonstrate the
statement was knowingly false and deliver
with malice with the intent to harm.
But under state law,
uh,
Oprah's burden was to demonstrate that
the statement is true with reasonable
certainty.
So I'll leave you with
one thought on this.
And,
uh,
the importance of fashioning
law in a way that would protect,
uh,
free speech and open access to knowledge
of risk and opinions on the part of
experts.
A Justice Powell in 1974
on truth and free speech,
there's no such thing as a false idea.
No matter how pernicious
and opinion may seem,
we depend on it's correction.
Uh,
not on the conscience
of judges and juries,
but on the competition of other ideas.
So that's it for today.
Have a great weekend.